ils ont décidé d'accueillir une famille
ukrainienne réfugiés ont ici on se sent
presque comme à la maison et surtout ce
n'est pas dangereux
il se trouve que les alpes maritimes
sont la première terre d'accueil après
la région ile-de-france de ces déplacés
ça nous ouvre la voie et la réflexion
sur qu'est-ce qu'un territoire
accueillant et comment on peut aller
plus loin on voit des gens courage
énorme de partir de 8 ans sans savoir où
vivent s'il n'y a pas un élan de
solidarité à ce moment là je sais pas
quand il pourra y avoir sénat en actions
réfugiés ukrainien france terre
d'accueil samedi à 17h30 sur public
sénat
[Musique]